я конфлікт цей штаб find so that
nothing in time ago пас Єгипті за
розпускали фаган ультой чапати новий
актіон
образ видосу basis and his and her fans
open а ну-ка of the stars зникають
момент розслідуваний від icm конфліктів там
wake бар'єр шиленко мінськ про це тобі
зайти до наших західних колег говорять
що не будуть, а не зніматимуть санкції своєї
ми не просимо це поки росія росія не
виконає мінські домовленості
виконувати ти повинні насамперед сторони
на які протистоять один одному це
донбас та українське українське
уряд ми реагуємо на те, як нас
по суті оточують оточення
натовськими озброєннями натовськими
підрозділами прямий на наших кордонах
з'являються підрозділів сухопутних
військ країн натомість до речі включати
георгій Німеччина Baalim аспект faresin
за його обличчям до кордону enemy to pass it
as we я я птахів янка предки ці кроковиком
beast is a crisis and ass wet що на
дошці та настася the first з мінська
agreement in за на зуб stance wotofo
факторизацію світ уже стає
об'єктивно стає пост західним
ніякого
moderno не вийшло і не вийде
потрібно звикати до того що світ буде
багатополярному і що потрібно перш за все
провідним гравцям свою колективну
відповідальність за мир та стабільність
усвідомлювати та реалізовувати на практиці
все can be seen болі про небезпеку зв'язок
. вона географія making sun on a ledge
enfants відшкодовує я доставка thunder та
справі зв'язок з аналізу заявлять iphone
менше на фанфа тотем покотилися постулат